um we are bringing you some breaking
news now because we have heard that
manchester united manager oligonosultia
has uh been sacked from manchester
united we can confirm actually he's left
the role as manager and of course he
joined manchester united
uh in december 2018 taking over uh from
jose mourinho at the
old trafford uh of course oligonous
soldier has had quite a difficult run
with manchester united a former player
the babyfaced assassin was an excellent
player and
we're understanding his left manchester
united um the transition into management
wasn't quite what we expected or what he
expected a big uh
fans loved olly gonna soldier but it
didn't really transition so just to re
repeat that breaking news olly gonna
soldier has left manchester united um
the club have confirmed that on twitter
in the last few minutes um saying that
we thank you for everything everything
ollie
as we said he took over from jose
mourinho in 2018 and the club have had a
bit of a dismal run um
actually so manchester united is
announcing that olly gonna soldier uh
has left his role as manager uh let's
just read that statement from the club
then they're saying ollie will always be
a legend at manchester united and it's
with regret they say
that they've reached this difficult
decision and while the past few weeks
have been disappointing they should not
obscure all the work he has done over
the past three years to rebuild the
foundations for long-term
success and ollie leaves with our
sincerest thanks they say for the
tireless efforts as manager and our very
best wishes for the future of course
they say his place in the club's history
will always
be secure not just for his story as a as
a player
but as a great man and a manager who
gave us many great moments and he will
forever be welcomed back at old trafford
as part of the manchester united family
and michael carrick will now take charge
of the team
and while the club looks to appoint an
interim manager for the rest of the
season so just to repeat that breaking
news
um
manchester united announcing in the last
few minutes that oligarcha is leaving
the club
and this is after a disappointing run
and of course that dismal 4-1 defeat at
watford
one of the worst displays of the
norwegians
tenure at the club
and we know that the 48 year old
was under review and there was constant
pressure after that that watford game um
and much speculation about whether it
would happen today or in the next few
weeks but just to repeat that manchester
united announcing uh that ollie gonna
salsa has left his role
as manager um he's been
a legend at the club that they say
a part of manchester united history of
course he was a player for many many
years a fantastic player known
as
the baby faced as snatching but let's
just hear from him this was a clip from
oligola soldier last night
that's five defeats out of the last
seven league games
would you understand if the board
decided to make a change
well i'm working for and with the club
and i've done that i've been there for
18 years and of course i'm
we've got a good communication and if if
the club
are thinking about doing something
that's
that's a conversation between us and not
you and me
so manchester united announces that olly
gunner soldier has left his role as
manager uh they released a statement to
us saying ollie will always be a legend
at manchester united and it's with
regret that we have reached this
difficult decision and while the past
few weeks have been disappointing they
should not obscure all the work he has
done over the past three years to
rebuild the foundations for long-term
success uh ollie lee's with our
sincerest thanks for his tireless
efforts as manager and our very best
wishes for the future they say his place
in the club's history will always be
secure not just for his story as a
player but as a great man and a manager
who gave us many great moments and he
will forever be welcomed back at old
trafford as part of the manchester
united family and just to say that
michael carrick will now take charge of
the team this breaking news in the last
few minutes that oligarch soldier will
be leaving manchester united he's had a
terrible run hasn't he in charge of the
club that five-nil loss at liverpool and
then a humiliating loss against
manchester city manchester rivals that
was a two-nil defeat and i think the now
in the coughing then was that 4-1 defeat
at watford
which
i guess broke the camel's back